[Musik]
natürlich ist super und ich sitze nicht
alleine wir sitzen noch gar nicht wir
stehen aber wenn wir fangen an
ich hab noch gar nicht erklärt was wird
machen und zwar spielen wir youtuber
strichmännchen beziehungsweise gallmann
beziehungsweise youtuber raten uns war
das eine challenge diesmal mit max
gemacht habe ich mache jetzt hier mit so
schwarzen mit einem schwarzen stift ein
youtuber namen hin und sie war es ja
muss buchstaben sagen muss
dementsprechend den youtube
wenn das nicht richtig
torrance leichtern hier sorry to me back
nine e bass oder das ist nicht der
dritte gestorben
nein nein nein hertha hörst richtiger
scheiß ich dachte erst mal ins den hat
deswegen dr aber dass er jetzt da ist
das projekt khk
das hätte ich diesen youtuber überhaupt
yahoo musste buchstaben tragen ja schon
vergeben gesagt ne davor war schon
verkorkst also für katz überleben so was
erklärt und dann taucht also ist eine
youtube bestehend aus vier buchstaben
und du meinst ich kenne diesen youtuber
wirklich ihr könnt übrigens war mit
raten in den kommentaren wird eh keiner
machen
ich warte jetzt einfach mal was dahin
bis dahin maß an die dritte stelle er ja
es ist wirklich nur gesagt weil ich
keine andere buchstaben gerade so hatte
ich jetzt draufgekommen
das kaputt gemacht der nächste youtube
machen ich habe auch viel buchstein
gemacht hat um maximal ein buchstabe
aber es ist der richtige kann aber keine
abkürzung ist dass der kanal habe okay
gibt es so bei youtube.com schrägstrich
und dann diese beiden buchstaben und
seither die url bsd gbp
leiter ist da was falsch wenn ich kriege
direkt hier zwei striche doch nur also
ps ich da nicht endlich gab ea werden
aber der ist es nicht gut gedacht
schlecht gemacht aber wir haben gelacht
und auch gepackt
beinahe zwei buchstaben in seine arbeit
niemand hat zwei buchstaben in seinem
plädoyer
nein den haben sie ist jetzt zu gedenken
den gibt's denn den jetzt schon mal
nicht doch den gibt es neben anderen
gemeinden gibt es in der inah
nein was das ist ja kein ausgedacht wenn
du das liest dabei gäste des übels
kratzt er sich dann dort gerade gekommen
weil ich wollte eigentlich erst eine
andere youtuber nehmen und arbeitest du
so eine kürzere als buchstaben dachte
ich okay wenn du willst dann denk kurzen
armen sind voll einfach aber es ist
nicht das schwierigste was drin sein
kann habe ich vielleicht für falsche
jetzt mit den ganzen buchstaben april
also eigentlich ist es kein pokal drin
bin ich mir da nicht dran dass k
19 schwarzkopf kanada 3 1 k s auch drin
oh mein gott freunde jetzt kommt der
letzte versuch von seefeld dieses worts
verraten sonst ehrlich eigentlich keine
ernst was ist das denn für die sache ist
wenn du es willst du dir denken 'oh mein
gott' alter oh mein gott wie komme ich
da nicht drauf kommt sie was ihr
plötzlich ios okay weil diese eine
webcam was gysi er hat lediglich die url
youtube.com / dc deswegen fahr alters
oder rad was jetzt hier acht als erstes
muss haben wir etwas schöner war es
einfach schön so was schönes interview
ich dachte das ist doch dass jetzt mehr
hat es nicht eilig nein das ist ja noch
im bett danach sein wird da werde auch
noch einmal gewiss nicht was ja wie eine
ewigkeit später leider falsch besonders
natürlich um die mitte
mai gefallen als ob nicht jetzt kann man
sagen ich schon wissen wer so gesicht
das richtige kick das bleibt ja kommt 97
40 sagen es nein es ist eine dritte wort
kommt schon gibt mir okay ich gehe
danke kein problem es ist nicht da ist
es nicht eher ist es nicht kann es ist
nicht nein nein nein nein nein du hast
du fragt was ist das denn 5 ich bin
nicht sicher ob du kennst aber ich denke
gesagt dass wir nur einen buchstaben
sagen dann kommt dreimal so einfordern
dann weiß man schon aber du hast du noch
einen buchstaben übrig welche buchstaben
können drei mal drin vorkommen dass ich
hier mal alle durch die man kaufen kann
sind allerdings überhaupt den pnn
jetzt wissen wir es war oder soll das
rätsel offen lassen
okay ich habe den punkt bekomme ich gebe
jetzt den buchstaben wo ich meine dass
er drei weiteren vorkommen
ja der mitmenschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abgestoßen es war natürlich
nicht fehlen
die comedy ich dachte wenn du das
zumindest noch sagt auf die bild ein
bisschen die vokale durchgehen du hast
jetzt a und o ist so selten alter okay
das ist wirklich für ihr stil ist nicht
auf dem berg dem was wir sagen
[Gelächter]
hmmm
leider kann das sein
am 12 also mein letzter youtuber muss
ganz ehrlich sagen den hatte ich auch
schon hast das video von mir gesehen wie
sehr kann ich über den buchstaben y
heute war so krass ist es okay dass
irgendwas englisch ist weil c ohne haar
ist sicher dass kein h drin ist ja wie
will man auf sie ist sie ohne irgendwas
machen
runde 21 kicker gibt wieder in schwung
das war zwar meine damen und herren wir
solche gefeiert das game ein leichter
selbst kann der beschreibung verlegen
jetzt kommt das auto hob das ziel von
bio das was jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken ihr findet hierzu andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnenten
seid könnt ihr auch die glocken klicken
dann willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]